comment ça se passe et schumi est hyper
du temps du corps m'a plutôt relax c'est
plutôt relax l'annoncé par et dax c'est
bon je vous emmène aujourd'hui au
huitième étage d'un immeuble à boulogne
billancourt bas loin de la scène pour
parler d'une marque beaucoup les sauts
de la déjà parlé le logo il a séché au
mixer les tout nouveaux locaux chili qui
vont récupérer la patrie au vent ça fait
quoi un mois qu'ils sont là on est au
huitième étage vous allez voir c'est
quoi encore
[Musique]
belle aux flots
henin ça quelle honte et chaussures
particulière celle et nous boudent un
[Musique]
avant après j'ai tendance à préférer
celle là n'est pas un si mauvais
photographe en fait moi je suis pas
d'accord c'est là et elle n'est pas
meilleure au monde benoît geoffroy est
comment ça se passe et schumi est hyper
du temps du corps plutôt relax c'est
plutôt relax là non c'est pas relax on
va c'est super aventure tombe bien ses
nouveaux locaux là ils s'en tiennent ils
sont canonici bockel
ton entre d'un côté là vous avez la
scène là bas vous avez la tour eiffel
surtout qui est énorme
la teuf et à boire et à manger du
pop-corn puisqu'il faut on est plutôt
pas mal donc l'idée aujourd'hui c'est de
vous faire un petit peu découvrir le off
voir ce qui se passe du côté de chez
tommy ma visite est très rapidement on
parle d'ici quelques jours à barcelone
par la nouvelle conférence par les 2009
qui aura probablement d'autres surprises
et ça on en parle tranquillement début
de semaine prochaine
ce soir c'est la fête on éprouvait
nouveaux locaux voilà ça va ça se passe
bien ne pas suivre
brooks et qui vient barcelone là
[Musique]
bon alors que la visite commence par la
cuisine parce que c'est pour moi le
poste le plus important dans une
entreprise sait où est ce qu'on va le
café où est ce qu'on mange
et voyez on est sur un univers ça fait
le tour complet on va par là derrière on
vient la salle de conférence et ouvre
alors pour l'occasion ils ont mis le
milazar projecteurs ou aura joué
effectivement à la console on a fait une
partie de mario kart alors ça déchire
combien de temps j'ai besoin de me
depuis qu'elle a cherché les tesselles
calme était celle-là tél on est prêt
ouais ouais ouais grande salle de kung
fu
c'est la grande classe innovation for
everyone
on retrouve là alors je dois continuer
la visite on a des photos dignes ifan ça
c'est plutôt cool là pour l'instant
c'est tous des postes qui sont inoccupés
parce qu'il passe quand même 2 34 mètres
carrés 40 mètres carrés à 450 mètres
carrés et si vous regarder au loin la
pop on devine tour eiffel là là mais bon
c'est très loin une petite salle de
réunion
les serveurs petit coin d'attendre
d'accueil autres salles de réunion un
bureau du boss ça va et là c'est
l'entrée bon bah c'est la réception ce
soir grande salle appareils comprennent
space tout le monde est beau c'est grâce
à ce match grâce à suarez bureau open
space tout le monde veut finalement
droit et là vous arrivez sur la partie
avec grand leygonie corporate sympa et
voyez là on a fait le tour et là on
retrouve au fond toute une partie où on
va avoir différents produits qui sont
exposés quelques-uns la trottinette le
réplicateur des pâtes smartphones et
puis des récompenses récompense des
numériques cinq attribués l'année
dernière pendant les dernières une
petite salle ici là probablement pour
pouvoir et ses petites filles on fouille
on y va peut-être pour recevoir du monde
s'isoler why you up on me de vince a vu
ça va c'est sympa très sympa savaria
ouais super locaux ce grand et la place
ouais vous avez encore la poste point qu
il ya beaucoup de collaborateurs et
j'imagine ouest le temps ouais c'est ça
vous êtes combien férié aujourd'hui la
jolie france pour l'instant les dix neuf
ans les magasins on attend donc 19 ici
au siège français sont d'accord et vous
pouvez cuire comme une personne fait ici
mais ici je crois que quand maxime euro
les ont vaincus lien entre 1,45 à 4,5
ouais ça fait déjà 2 à pas mal bon
potentiel doublé l'effectif c'est énorme
ça se passe bien pour chez auguste année
alors c'est vrai que bon vous êtes
arrivé en france
owen dernière
beaucoup d'évolutions beaucoup de
magasins ouverts l'un des nouveaux
locaux flambant neufs
c'est quoi la prochaine étape pour ce qu
il se passe tellement de choses et ça se
passe très vite en très honnêtement il
ya huit mois pour la survie c'est tout
seul quoi la presse plus à passer trois
à cinq qui la suite aux mouz maintenant
on est en les 17 18 19 donc du coup ça a
évolué très vite
hoyé au début on est dans un sens un
prince qui intrigue le 35 mètres carrés
où les gamins sur l'autre tout gêne
personne
c'était vraiment je tiens à remercier
tous les collaborateurs et avec leur
patience nous analyse d'avoir supporté
pendant six mois dans 1 30 mètre carré
maintenant pour y célébrer un peu de
confort pour les way ont été employés
pour le comparateur ou qui plus est
vraiment de la techno leur talent aux
îles on se pose dans le bureau comme si
je me serais chez choc alors pourquoi je
vous parle de
je vous fait visiter en tout cas les
locaux tiennent aujourd'hui tout
simplement parce que j'aime bien pouvoir
rentrer un peu dans les coulisses
découvrir voir comment ça se passe pour
vous montrer le faire partager avec vous
parce que la marque vous la connaissez
quand vous allez dans les stores ce que
vous voulez éviter lorsque vous
découvrez mais découvrir comme ça des
bureaux voir comment ça se passe en
interne directement dans une boîte et
c'est strictement impossible donc ça
c'est cool que chez tommy nous a ouvert
les portes dans le cadre de cette
inauguration ça vous permet de découvrir
ça me permet aussi de le partager avec
vous alors c'est pas du tout une vidéo
sponsorisés absolument pas par contre
l'idée c'est effectivement de partager
donc dites moi ce que vous en pensez ce
que ça vous botte des vidéos comme ça on
est un peu dans les coulisses d'une
boîte mais c'est de voir un peu ce qui
se passe comment ça se passe vous
marquez tout ça et si ça vous tente
peut-être qu'on fera ça plus tard avec
d'autres groupes d'autres entreprises
pourquoi pas voilà d'ici là soyez sages
et à très bientôt donc
non